if you look at somebody like Hitler
it's difficult to know what was going on
in his mind but it's possible to imagine
if you just look at dictator's thought
history that he thought he was doing
good not just for himself but for the
people he believed have value so one way
you can have what you can achieve what
we consider is evil
is uh by devaluing some group of people
and uh that could be all group of people
so it could have sort of a narcissistic
type of idea that you basically don't
care about other human beings that's one
Envy is different I mean maybe they can
collaborate together uh or even uh like
you mentioned you can actually enjoy
doing bad to others that's almost like
different because if if all it is is
like narcissism uh you disregard you
don't care what how others feel then you
can just have make cold calculated
military almost economic decisions and
you don't care if a million people die
here or there but if you actually enjoy
some aspect of that or there is like a
resentment that fuels it it's not just
cold calculation it's like fueled by
some kind of personal or uh cultural
resentment by that you think so I think
it's all field but I think the idea that
say Hitler thought he was doing good
good right it is like that is such a
thin facade that it flies away like a
handkerchief in a hurricane right that
okay yeah thank you that's wow that's
beautiful yeah it's it's built upon like
it says I'll explain logical lies right
because people can build lies upon
specious logic right so the idea that
okay I am doing good because I believe
that this
um ethnicity of people is good and this
is bad and now I'm going to do this and
I'm going to make the world different
and it's going to bring better to the
world and now I'm raising armies and I'm
building concentration camps and I think
like this is all in the service of good
is I don't I don't think anyone ever
thinks that right or they they think
that but with because they're living in
the surface patina right like they're
not allowing the hurricane in that blows
away the handkerchief and says like this
is all this is all this is all evil
right I mean how do you decide that some
group of people is good and some is bad
and like what what is it that you take
upon yourself to to to play God or make
decisions about the world and I think
what really is going on as people are
not doing that right there's something
cobbled together to say like why this is
right and this is okay right and this is
even good right but it is all
a lie right it's a lie that's adorning
the the what I believe is the fact I
believe that what's going on is the
gratification of Envy inside of the
person and whether someone says oh I
think this is good and it's okay if a
million people die or I'm going to enjoy
that a million people die I think is the
same I think the the enjoyment the
gratification of the orchestrated evil
is there and that it all comes from
vulnerability and insecurity it all
comes from deficits in the sense of self
right I'm gonna have to process that
my my my slow Penny and PC is processing
that so Envy underlies all of it the
psychological concept of envy
what is that
I keep putting myself in the mind of
Hitler I guess that that has nothing to
do it doesn't have to do with uh Jews or
Slavic people does it have to do with
specific amorphous
other
in his mind that he's envious of I think
it has all to do with him
all to do with him there's not a love of
the people with whom he Allied or even a
sense of the people who he persecuted
were worse than him it's all projections
out of what was going on inside of him
which was an intense sense of inadequacy
a rage at being someone he perceived as
lesser than that's the difference
between so we can define words in
different ways even within psychology
but let's say we take the definition
here of jealousy as being sort of benign
right the idea that oh I might see
something that you have that I don't and
I might think I'd like that maybe I'll
work harder to get it right or maybe I
can't get it maybe it's that you're
younger than I am they say okay you know
okay you know you have that and I don't
I mean I have other things too I'm okay
anyway but I might want those things but
it's very benign the jealousy I'd like
to be younger I'd like to be richer
whatever it is that we people think
right
but it's just a thought and it's a
thought that can result in strivings or
acceptance right it's very very
different it's completely different than
Envy which is destructive it's the
thought of I see something that you have
that I don't have right and instead of
me working for it or accepting that I
don't have it what I'd like to do then
is bring you down
take you down to where I am and then
I'll feel better right because from the
perspective of Envy it is all relative
those jealousy a kind of is is a book
because he said completely different but
it's jealousy potentially like a gateway
drug to Envy like does it does it like
is it a slippery slope I think no I
think that jealousy is a natural just
part of the human phenomenon that we go
through life and we see like oh I'd like
to have I think it's probably part of
our incentives right if you know if if
I'm Farming and I have one row of crops
and I look over and I see that you're
working harder and you have two and I'd
like to have two that can make me work
harder to have two you don't think it's
slippery slope from one to the other to
at first you're like I'd like to work
harder but then you keep failing and the
weather sucks and you keep failing and
the other person becomes more successful
plus he's got a new hot wife now there's
a nice tractor uh does it feel this all
working and then you get this idea that
you know what I'm gonna steal all this
stuff I'm gonna murder him and that you
know don't you think that's just like a
leap no I actually think it's the same
phenomena no no because but I think
there are things that are in us as
humans right so so the things are just
by being human like we can for example
feel we can feel compassion right we can
feel interest right we can feel jealousy
in in that benign sense like it's all
part of just being human if we if we
start going from hey you have more crops
than I have and and you know that seems
like actually have a better life in a
lot of ways than I have I'm gonna kill
you that that's not that is not a
progression of something benign right
that is wait wait a minute but there is
a human leap of the same thing isn't it
is because you're drawing a line stuff
you're saying like this is the this
human stuff this regular life it's
benign
but it feels like this benign thing is
just a low magnitude thing
version of the thing that's not benign
like there's there's probably a gray
area where it stops being put like
jealousy you can have like healthy gel
so you can have a little bit slightly
unhealthy there's a that's I think
Jealous Guy this John Lennon song that I
love is just beautiful I mean there's
like this jealousy inside relationships
can make you feel like uh you know take
your minds in all kinds of silly
directions and it's crazy but like it
feels like that that's an extra neighbor
to like being really crazy and toxic and
all that kind of stuff inside
relationships and then that feels like a
next door neighbor it's like an
apartment building that feels like an
extra neighbor uh that eventually gets
to Hitler with uh with envy and
resentment of entire population of
people you're writing that there's a
causal yeah there can be a causal chain
right like if I'm not feeling jealous
maybe I won't ever feel envious right so
so you can see okay so it can kind of
lead to it can open gates to huh like
how much do I dislike that you have
things that I don't have right so yes in
that sense but and I think this
department I think is so important that
I think there is a disjunction right
it's there's an asymptotic shift right
from one thing to another because if you
speak in my language mathematically yeah
yep yes that that's it's a way to convey
right something that's entirely
different because if I start thinking
you know I'm not going to try and make
things better right I'd like instead to
harm you that's that's qualitatively
different oh it's almost like you know
what it is it could be I don't know what
you think about this but
is uh in which direction
your motivation is pointing
so if in the response to the feeling of
jealousy
your sort of
um the motivation says okay I understand
this feeling I want to do less of it
I think there's there must be a
threshold to which you actually want to
do more like it becomes a vicious
downward cycle so that's what Envy
becomes like the first feeling this idea
that I'm gonna kill the farmer
it turns into like more and more and
more and you can't sleep and you're
visualizing the farmer and it becomes
the devil and like you have this very
you know it's it's a it's basically a
thing that builds into the negative
Direction versus returns to the stable
Center yeah now a person is cultivating
evil yeah right they're saying hey there
can be seeds of Evil in all of us let me
take that seed out dust it off plant it
nurture it right and then grow that seed
of evil which will affect all other
parts of the person's life right they
they won't behave the same towards
others in their in their life they'll
they'll they'll become different as they
nurture fantasies of evil as they begin
to create with side within inside of
themselves the the motivation and the
will right to enact evil right the
Hitler analogy would say look you take
someone who had a bad childhood right
who who like was not loved who who was
taught and told that he was less than
okay like that when we know that happens
I mean that's why child abuse is so evil
right it's telling children the the
worst possible wrong lessons right
they're not good enough they'll always
be hurt you know they can't keep
themselves safe they don't deserve
safety right so then you take someone
who then nurtures that seed of evil
which is a choice and says well I can't
paint well enough and no one appreciates
me and I don't like how I look and I
don't fit in with the people I want to
fit in with and then and on and on and
on and on and on and there's a hatred of
self through that lens of misery of just
being repulsed by the self but that's
unacceptable to the self so oh it has to
be someone else's fault
right it's not my fault whose fault is
it right and then you see on mass the an
action of evil towards groups of people
who who somehow in this person's mind
right are responsible for his misery and
there's the justification of evil and
then all the you know whether it's this
will be better for the economy this will
be good this will be that like that's
all lies built to justify the evil those
are surface level narratives yes
and the Envy is the the deep down
mechanism that enables and that's the
endpoint that's being served what's
being served is destruction right which
is why it always brings more destruction
right I mean how many times do do
Wars that were started for purposes that
we would look and say like those were
evil purposes like how many times
does good come of that even we look at
the modern world what comes of it is
more evil is more destruction you know
Hitler's outward destruction eventually
came Inward and you know you see
pictures of what Berlin looked like
after the second world war right it
wasn't just destruction perpetrated
outward as awful as that is it's it's
it's catchy right like people used to
worry if you you know before the during
the time of the Manhattan Project right
if you start this Chain Reaction you
know will you blow the whole world up
right or will it stop within this bomb
or not and we see okay the chain
reaction of evil hasn't yet blown the
whole world up but look at the look at
how the catastrophe spreads and you
think 50 to 60 million people dead in
the second world war which truly was a
World War what destruction was spread
around the globe and this is something
that can't be stopped once the Chain
Reaction starts like if Hitler was
successful like it would just keep going
if he had been thinking if it's personal
psychological level I mean right because
we think from the perspective of
Destruction success would have needed
led to the need to conquer more then
there's factions and infighting and then
eventually you get the same mass
destruction right and and never does the
inaction of evil satisfy what the person
is initially seeking like people want to
feel better about themselves right we
like winicot who was uh a British uh
pediatrician who who wrote about
children and adults from a very deep
perspectives he wrote about the idea of
good enough right and then you can sort
of extrapolate that like we all want to
feel good enough like not just limp over
the line good enough but I want to feel
good enough that I'm a decent person in
the world and like what I do matters and
you know I can I can have an impact on
people and you know people can like me
and care about me it's there's a
Simplicity there that people want that
when people don't have and there's
certain other factors maybe they're
temperamental factors or historical
factors can lead to trying to soothe the
that deficit right through envy and and
I think it starts with with it starts
with that and it often starts in
childhood not always but it often starts
in childhood when when the child's brain
and psychology are so vulnerable and you
know you see Salient child abuse if you
know if you look at what was Hitler's
background and what was Stalin's
background and I mean you could you
could look at almost anyone who's
perpetrated evil or they're serial
killers or whatever it may be the the
majority not everyone but the majority
had these lessons in childhood that said
you're not good enough you can't keep
yourself safe no one cares about you and
and in a subset of people that's going
to generate envy and that you know that
that seed of evil then gets planted and
nurtured
as a fighter jet for us above us the
sound of a fighter Jen above us it's
been good if I had Orchestra you forget
you quickly forget the comfort of being
in a peaceful place that's one thing I
saw in Ukraine
is um
hey you quickly get comfortable here the
whole trip back
I was thinking it's so damn good to be
in America the whole just a whole like
it's like a three day trip back it's so
good to be American
we might take that for granted
as a population but I do agree
so the destruction never alleviates the
envy
are all humans capable of envy
I believe the answer is yes if you think
do we all have the possibility of evil
in us I think the answer to that is yes
but we have
free will we have choice we we can
choose what we do with that which is why
just because someone is a sociopath you
know for example is it doesn't mean that
they're not responsible I mean our you
know our medical legal jurisprudence
right has
um has absolutely borne that out that
legally medically we think okay if we're
responsible presuming we're healthy
we're not unhealthy in other ways it
eliminates our ability to to to be
circumspect but that we're responsible
for what we do and don't nurture inside
of us I mean there are plenty of things
we could decide to nurture anger and
hatred about you know I could think of
slights difficulties whether it's
something someone else has done to me or
I could blame fate or I could be mad at
God or the world we can all make those
choices and we're responsible for them
or if we're recognizing things in us
they're like oh I you know I too have
that in me but I don't want to nurture
that I don't want to Foster that or do I
choose to nurture and Foster that and I
think ultimately in our subject of
Hitler as as evil if Hitler had kept
winning and winning right I think
ultimately he would have been the only
person on Earth
right and I really do believe that
ultimately everyone everything else
would be killed because it's such
destruction right destroy everything
right and probably when that didn't work
then there's the destruction of the self
right because
nothing
soothes
envy that is stoked by the sort of
flames of evil and what you see is more
and more anger and more and more
frustration which is why I really do
believe someone like that who who
nurtured evil in themselves that way
ultimately would would destroy they'd be
like him and one other person then he'd
kill the other person I think that's
really powerfully said but even just to
return to the jealousy versus Envy I
still think that it's the same Flame
and envy is just the bigger version of
it so I I think
I just in my own personal life
I've felt jealousy towards others like
you said like oh this person
has a I don't know a cooler thing drink
it whatever trinket I cared about and
usually it's when somebody's really
close to the the trinket You're Building
uh and I I early on like in my teens
I realized that
just just empirically speaking that
jealousy over a period of a week just
doesn't feel good
and it's not productive it doesn't help
me build a better trinket
um or it does if I turn it not into
jealousy
towards another person but into a love
for building a better trinket it's like
oh cool almost you know what like
proactively speaking and later in life
like people like Joe Rogan actually have
been really uh powerful in this for me
just as a fan of his
to celebrate other people so it's almost
as opposed to ignoring that other person
with a cool trinket is like celebrating
their awesomeness in my mind yeah like
just saying how awesome the humans are
able to do that and actually just how
awesome is that exact person and being
able to do that yeah and that somehow
made me more capable to build my own
trinket better yes and it feels good
also like it makes me feel happy and now
you're not jealous anymore you're not
jealous anymore right so that's why I
think jealousy is different right
because he's saying there's a week of
jealousy like I don't like this right I
don't like but if you take that in a way
that says wait sir actually this is
awesome this is fabulous and this person
did this that person's awesome right
then then what you're not raining on
anyone's parade right and in not doing
that even inside your own mind you you
gain a greater cognizance of your own
capability right well if he if he can do
that or she can do that what why can't I
too like I want to build I want to make
the better trinket too right yeah now
you're thinking creatively nowhere in
there
nowhere in there was the emergence of
evil I just disagree with that I think
there was a choice made where I I looked
at my if my life was darker more
difficult I think it has nothing to do
with the actual little flame of jealousy
I felt I think he has to do a lot more
with the other context if if I
if if my life were more difficult there
was more abuse there was more challenges
I think that decision I could have made
that decision a different direction yes
maybe I don't know
um yeah you you've written brilliantly
about trauma if there's a bit more
trauma as the background noise of my
decision making I'll be more likely to
uh not be able to pull away from the
gravitational field of that jealousy and
would build and build and build and
build so I think I it's not to disagree
with the brilliant a person but like I
feel like that claim that flame has the
capacity to engulf the whole world I
guess the initial flame of jealousy is a
little bit like especially the Younger
You Are
it's a it's almost like a habit you get
to build in either direction because
I've early on built a habit of saying
I'm going to uh channel that jealousy uh
into productivity and into celebrating
other people in that jealousy disappears
that was like a little Discovery for me
I discovered that I get it that doesn't
come nobody tells that to you you kind
of discover that little thing I could
have easily not discovered it I could
have easily discovered
that it kind of feels good to to like
mess with that other person to like uh
think uh shitty thoughts think negative
thoughts do negative things to the other
person because that could also I I just
think the capacity in that initial
feeling is there and I think it's the
decision we make because like otherwise
I think it dissolves responsibility
like well surely I'm not Hitler
therefore this jealousy is normal no I
just feel like every jealousy has the
capacity to turn into maybe not Hitler
but a toxicity that destroys in a small
way in your own little private life but
it could destroy I agree that
jealousy brings us
can bring us dangerously close to Envy I
mean maybe maybe let's see if if
um a heuristic we could agree on right
let's see so let's say okay if we look
at the terrain of the mind is geography
right so if I'm feeling happy satisfied
proud like I'm pretty far from from Envy
land right right but but if I'm feeling
jealousy now I'm I'm I'm coming kind of
closer to that border right and
I still I think there's it's a big thing
to go over the border right if the
Border isn't a gray area right there's a
border to go over and I think that you
you I agree completely once certainly
about trauma that the more trauma there
is because then the more
misunderstandings there are about self
and feelings that I'm not good enough
and then that can be anger about why and
who might be oppressing me and you know
I hate myself and everyone else who
seems to be better like so the trauma
can drive us in these negative
directions but we're still crossing over
something right so so if you have the
trinket and I think that's awesome I
want that I want to work harder you know
what I could do though is I could sneak
in tonight when no one's around and I
could move something around no no way I
don't want to do that right but it's
like I came over the Border a little bit
and I thought maybe maybe that's a
better way but then I came back right
and I'm and you're we're responsible for
that right because it is a choice to say
I don't want to work hard I'm already
working how how hard I don't want to
make my trinket better I want to think
mine's the best one I could destroy
yours right then you know we're letting
our mind go over that border and do we
say right run that forward right let's
run that forward and put people around
us who feel the same way and start doing
it so we think less of ourselves and we
debase ourselves do we run headlong in
or do we come over that boundary and
that's maybe the capacity for evil in us
that we come over that boundary all of
us right at times but do we come over it
and then said no that that's not my
choice that's not my self-definition and
I'm coming back but I'm trying to
justify maybe there are certain other
sociological forces that help us cross
the border too so in Nazi Germany we've
been talking about Hitler but then
there's also the the German people and
so maybe when there's a bit of a mass
hysteria so all these effects of like uh
combination of propaganda with the small
jealousies and resentments of the people
that don't cross the border uh together
they can with with great charismatic
leaders that sort of uh really fueled
that fire that we feel when we're a part
of the crowd so maybe those individual
kind of psychological barriers we have
to take that leap from jealousy to Envy
those can be made easier the the leap
can be catalyzed through this mess 100
100 I think that to me is a massive
point we're talking about layers of
emergence right so if there's individual
Consciousness then there's culture right
and you know we're products of the soup
we swim in so to speak people would say
that when I was growing up right we're
products of the soup we swim in so if
the soup that we're swimming in is the
soup of hatred yeah right then it's
going to Foster all of those things so
then you think about just in a painting
with a very broad brush the culture
created in Germany prior to the second
world war and like what was the impact
of the reparations after the first world
war right of the the punishing
reparations impoverishment and you know
and basically humiliation right that
people were feeling okay like that's
there were a whole bunch of decisions
that impacted that cultural perspective
right then there must have been aspects
just like I see in many ways parallels
in in America now of what are our
standards for what we're communicating
to others right how is the media
deciding like what's real and what's not
real what's true what's not true what's
hatred that that is only going to do
evil versus what's hatred that's okay
because I might sell something by by
putting it out there I mean that was we
know that was going on in Germany during
the rise of the Nazis and and I think
there's a parallel to you know do we
value truth do can we stand together and
say no matter how much I might disagree
with you politically right we can still
understand like that there's there's
right and there's wrong right there's
truth and there's lies right so so I
think those are just two examples of
determinants of culture and then the
culture is a determinant of you know is
someone like Hitler marginalizes like
that's a that's a crazy evil person oh
my goodness like whoa right or is that
someone who gains a greater following a
more adherence and then there starts to
be a momentum because why because what
do demagogues do I think they they have
a giant lasso and they harness the Envy
of of thousands upon thousands upon
thousands of people that's right you
feel worse about yourself too doesn't
matter what the reasons are maybe it's
your childhood maybe it's not maybe it's
job failings maybe it's professional
maybe it's personal it doesn't matter
like you have nv2
let's put it together and do some
destruction because that'll make us feel
better which is a lie